tu fais râble divorce agence y'est je
suis pour divorcer ou encore la
contraception
moi de toute façon j'ai perdu un enfant
comme ça
et oui la contraception ça existait pas
b
mais j'ai toujours regretté tu penses
que tu vas le leader du bas c'est parce
que je savais que je pouvais garder mais
à ce moment là que c'était beau sortir
un peu du kursaal à thouars rien ou
marques avec la mère que j'ai j'aurais
pu aider on va jouer dix après c'est
trop tard et je regrette l'absence
pourquoi quelquefois toi ma fille
c'était pas prévu le petit garçon m et
puis elle m'a dit moi je suis enceinte
je lui ai dit écoute tu gardes je peux
pas expliquer pourquoi parce que je suis
d'avis comme ça qu'il avait fait et je
suis dit je t'en supplie garde le pas ce
que fit la mosquée au faux c'est pas toi
qui le décide c'est en voyant les gens
qui me disent à des pigeons jamais
d'enfant et roland faut c'est décidé ils
vont arriver
donc je pense que moi je regrette ça
pour moi voilà si j'avais le cloud g22
une possibilité est de savoir ça parce
que je savais pas ensemble et je te dire
que je vous ai bien c'est un miracle
continue et il faut garder à ce qu'il y
ait une raison profonde et ça j'y crois
complètement
l'étude n'a pas le droit d'arrêter c'est
que ça voilà c'est possible le togo
situé favorablement
oui pour le coup pas enlever mais ça va
pas le faire maintenant
abbas à elle est partie celle là
j'espère qu'il repart on va dire tout
haut on dit tu crois que tu crois en
dieu même si tu l'appelles peu dieu il
faut croire à quelque chose parce que
marié alors ça veut dire que tu es dans
le désert des dunes vide qui assurent le
pool de tout à l'heure et puis tu
plonges pourquoi pas ou que tu peux te
féliciter si t'es pas tenus par des
règles et des raids des choses
quelquefois bois c'est un souhait que
quelqu'un sait séduire émissions aux
amoureux lot de du plaisir je suis
heureux de vivre suis heureuse comptant
alors voilà je suis bien mais nous aussi
au lieu des 13 autres et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux